Alright, so the first problem is false,
and this comes from the definition of NP-completeness.
By definition since SAT is in NP-complete,
every problem in NP can be reduced to it in polynomial time,
so there can't exist NP problems that can't be transformed
into SAT in polynomial time.
The second problem is also false.
Nondeterministic RAMs don't give different results for the same decision problem.
This is something that a lot of people have problems with,
but the key is that  nondeterminism isn't the same thing as randomness.
At each step, remember whenever the if better procedure is called,
it makes the best possible decision,
so it's not going to make a random one,
and it's going to make the same best possible decision every time,
so it won't give different results for the same decision problem.
The third problem is also false.
A problem with exponential possible solutions can only be in P if P equals NP.
A good problem to see this on is sorting.
Whenever you sort a list of N elements, let's say,
there are exponentially many different possible sorts,
but actually, there are quite a few sorting algorithms that
can find the correct sort of an element list
in much shorter than exponential time,
so this is actually not true.
The fourth problem, just like the other 3, is also false.
It is not true that every program that takes exponential time
on a deterministic machine can be made to run in
polynomial time on a nondeterministic machine,
and good examples of this are any program where the
output size is exponential in the input size.
For example, if you have a list of N elements
and then you want to print out all possible sub lists,
then the fact that you have to print out every single possible sub list,
of which there are exponentially many in the input size of the list,
means that if better doesn't actually buy you anything.
You still have to explore the entire exponential space,
so even a nondeterministic machine
will have to take exponential time in that case.